Hello,
welcome.
It is June 26th, 2025
and we are live in active inference
guest stream 113.1.
Welcome Jack as well. We are with Sergio
Jacis and we will be discussing basing
mechanics of economic choice
computational foundations of economic
behavior. There will be a presentation
followed by a discussion. So thank you
again for joining and looking forward to
the presentation.
Thank you for joining Jack and thank you
for the active inference community for
inviting me to share my my current
research. Uh as Daniel said I am Samuel
or Sergio I have both names. Uh I am
residing in Mexico City. I am a
secondyear PhD candidate in artificial
intelligence and my current research
basically focuses on applying the active
inference framework to understand
economic choice and financial decisions.
Uh just to notice that this is joint
work with Ernesto Moya, PhD, my thesis
supervisor and Luis Alberto Casada, PhD
as well, which are two Mexican academics
as well. Well, let's begin.
So
basically I'm going to be speaking a lot
about this paper that we recently
published but I'm also going to give you
a brief introduction about the main
themes that we are trying to bring
together which are basically
topics from neurokconomics topics
naturally from basin mechanics and the
active inference framework and topics
from classical or neocclassical
economics and psychology. So we're given
that we are trying to merge all of those
fields and as you probably know here in
the community the free energy principle
is very interdisciplinary itself. So I
think I would take some time to explain
the intellectual journey of these
different fields and how we think they
nicely come together. So we'll start
with economics. Then we would move to
how psychology meets economics. Then a
little bit of the thermodynamics of
information both for neuroeconomics and
active inference and then how the
divisive normalization model from
neuroeconomics can be derived formally
from the free energy principle. Uh so
that's the basic or the key insight from
our per our paper. And finally I'll I'll
share some of the future directions or
the future work that we intend to pro to
do for this year or the end of this
year. So let's start.
So I would like to start by
by sharing the let's say the
intellectual journey of how economist
usually think about valuation and about
encoding value. So let's start with the
Swiss mathematician uh Daniel Bernuli
and as you probably know he's very well
known for creating uh classical utility
theory or expect or classical expected
utility theory which basically said that
that economic agents or people don't
encode does don't encode absolute
monetary values. We don't encode
absolute monetary values. we encode what
he called moral value and moral value
was just a way of saying subjective
value. So monetary values are are I mean
are subjective on how much we want
something on the time we are on the on
the place we are. So basically that's
what he formalized and he formalized it
as a weighted sum of expected
probabilities and payoffs. Now later on
very famously von Noyman and Morgan stem
published their famous work theory of
games and economic behavior where many
of you listening uh probably have heard
it because it that was the the
foundation of game theory but one key
insight and was that when they published
this work they just expanded Berni's
expected utility theory to account for
the specific axioms that economic agents
should abide to in order to be what we
usually came to to refer to as rational
to make rational decisions or rational
rational choices. So these uh these
axiums were that our decisions would be
should be complete they should be
transitive and this this is very very
important. So when I prefer A to B and B
to C uh we should follow this this this
ordinal uh property and our choices
should be value independent independent
of the other choices independent of past
choices. So that was another another
choice and if we if our rational agent
or our economic agent abides by these
axioms the key point here is that what
naturally follows and can be derived
mathematically is that this agent would
be maximizing its expected utility. And
this is key because this is another way
for example in the active inference uh
slang or language that this economic
agent would be pursuing a goal. So it's
another way of saying it it's going to
be focused on goal directedness.
So so just keep that in mind and we will
see how that impacts us later. So this
this framework uh basically impacted all
of neocclassical economics and modern uh
economic development. And another key
aspect of Bonoyman and Morgansson's
theory is that they thought of the
probabilities of events and the payoffs
as objective. So what I mean what what
do we refer with that? For example, if
we are going to roll a dieice, we know
that we know the exact probabilities and
we can compute them exactly
analytically. So that's pretty much what
they what they meant that we know the
the objective probabilities of specific
economic outcomes and we know the
payoffs in advance. However, naturally
you can start thinking that that's
rarely the case with the exception of
for example uh specific uh random games
or casino like games. later on Sapul
Samuelson uh which probably one of the
let's say leading figures in the in in
economics in your case in economics uh
came to say that we really don't know
the preferences of economic agents or
economic agents uh I mean we cannot get
inside their brains to know their
preferences so in their in his paper
consumption theory in terms of revealed
preference he just say he basically said
we cannot know the preferences in
advance But we can observe their choices
and infer their preferences. So it was
that was that was the first type of a
bit of basian approach to economic
decisionm. But later on Leonard Leonard
Savage or better known as Jimmy Savage
uh famously published the foundations of
statistics in the 1950s where he
established subjective expected utility
theory meaning that he established that
we definitely don't know the preferences
in advance uh and we don't know the
objective probabilities. The only thing
we have is beliefs. Beliefs like in the
the active inference framework. So those
beliefs are subjective probabilities.
However, one important aspect here is
that even though he established that we
will have these beliefs and these
objective probabilities, this would be a
normative theory. So normative theory is
a way for economist to say rational
because many many people not coming not
acquainted with a theory of economics uh
hear rational and they just think of I
don't know like capital spuck or
something like that. So when we say
rational we really say normative and
what we refer to is that the economic
agent is making logically consistent
choices abiding by these axioms
transitivity independence uh
completeness and we can also add
continuity.
All right so that's basically how
rational choice theory evolved from its
beginning and pretty much up to
nowadays.
Now then
many many other researchers and
economists came to say all right so
that's the theory but let's observe how
do people actually behave so let's build
a descriptive theory not an not a
normative theory of how people should
behave uh and the first uh key figure in
this story it's Maurice Allayi uh which
was a French economist uh he also was
another laurate in economics and he came
up what later became known for uh as the
the ally paradox. So the ally paradox
basically said that
many sophisticated decision makers
including leading economists like Jimmy
Savage consistently violated the
independence axiom that we just referred
to. So so what what did did that mean?
That basically meant that when facing
different choices and rearranging the
the many of choices or the opportunity
set of choices even novel laurate
economist didn't abide by the the
independence aim. So that was one of the
first uh let's say empirical validations
that that the axons of rational choice
theory were consistently violated even
by the people that came up or that that
that developed the theory for them.
Later on and most famously canners
introduced uh psychology into economics.
So that was the point where psychology
formally met economics and they they
came up with a formal descriptive theory
which was later called prospect theory
in the 19 1980s. Uh so basically
prospect theory was
an empirical theory contrary to the
previous theories which were mainly
theoretical and they literally observed
how people make economic decisions under
uncertainty and they come came up with a
graph here that we have in the right
hand side corner which you can see that
has a sigmoid function. So let's
contrast that function with the classic
utility theory function from Brendle
Lee. So you can see that the classic
utility function from Brendle Lee is
basically explaining what we usually
learn about in economics 101 which is
diminishing marginal returns. Uh we
experience diminishing marginal returns.
That's the basic the basic utility
function. But what Cananan and Tverki
find out was that that was not how
people behave in reality. They observed
that they behaved like this uh with this
utility function which is this sigmoid
shaped utility function. And the key
aspect of this utility function is that
there's a discontinuity between gains
and losses. they are they more or less
found that uh people or the brain
registers with twice the intensity
losses to gains. So that was a key key
insight and a key violation of
traditional rational choice axioms. Uh
so we can speak about a discontinuity
between gains and losses. uh and
popularly this this theory came to be
known as the let's say irrational
argument for for economic behavior or
economic decision- making. Uh but the
the the thing was that many economists
push back against this and many other
decision scientists push back against
this because this theory essentially
said people take behave and take
irrational decisions very often. they
are subject to biases. They take a lot
of their decisions with heristics that
make them fall into traps. So
essentially he was saying that people
people are not very smart. People are
idiots even. So that's what they said.
Now later on uh Richard Taylor and
Loenstein and other relevant figures who
will also would be well in the case of
Richard Taylor was also awarded the
nobility in economics uh pretty much
imported prospect theory formally into
economics and establish what we now know
as a field of behavioral economics which
is accounting for these uh biases and
heristics into economic decision-m and
pretty much checking how consistently
these biases eristics make us violate
the traditional actions of neocclassical
economics. However, however
they I mean everything was like Paul
Samuelson said it we infer the
preferences we infer what is happening
in the brain by observing behavior. It
was still not uh a neurohysiological
theory or anything like that. So that
was pretty much how we have been uh
evolving. Now let's move let's switch
breaks and let's move to some other
things happening specifically in
computational neuroscience. So in
computational neuroscience more or less
in the same along the same time uh there
were a lot of very interesting
discoveries. So famously, Simon
Laughlin's 1981 study of fly photo
receptor neurons demonstrated that the
optimal computation under constraints
under energy constraints would be one
that look like this where where the fly
or in this case that the the flies
neurons photo receptors would spend more
on representational resources uh on the
parts that were more common or more
likely to appear. Meaning that for
example for certain light intensity that
was more common to appear in in its
environment the fly or the the flight
photo receptor neurons would encode
those would give a higher probability of
encoding that level of light more often
than very rare events in its
environment. So basically what what we
are seeing is that the fly photo
receptors are mapping the environmental
statistics in order to optimize or to
compress the amount of limited energy it
has in its brain. So as we know uh
neural computation is very expensive.
The brain even though it's it's only
more or less 2% of the body's weight it
uses about a fifth of the body's energy.
So, so the so naturally that means that
it's very metabolically costly and it
needs to be very very efficient on using
that energy for its rep representational
capacity and also we can bring uh
evolution and adaptiveness to the to the
mix because naturally the fly as long as
it performs this type of action and
other type of actions better uh is going
to be able to survive. uh I mean it just
is just going to be able to adapt uh
more more optimally. Then we we can also
introduce Landau's principle from Rol
Landau who said decreasing stoasticity
in choices decreases information entropy
and later the in the famous infomax
principle which says the brain optimizes
mutual information between output and
input. So that basically said we have we
have an for example for the fly the fly
has an unlimited number of pixels that
or the of just stimuli that it has to
encode but it has a very limited input
capacity. So it has to compress that and
it compresses that by assigning
different weights and assigning higher
probabilities to the in this case the
light intensities that that came that
came up more often. And when when we
take the integral of that function, we
can see that we're going to see this
sigmoidal this sigmoidal uh shape or the
sigmoidal uh CDF. So just remember that
because that's going to came up later.
All right. So how can we take these
these insights and bring them back to
economic to economic decision making? So
if we assume what rational choice theory
said to us that we essentially make
uniform uh we make decisions with
uniform precision we don't have
information asymmetries as new classical
economics said then what that means in
terms of information processing is that
neocclassical economies like bonoyman
and morgan assume that there was no cost
in representation.
So and we can translate that uh
geometrically as uniform precision and
you can see as you can see in the graph.
So without depending on the reward
magnitude the fine rate is going to
increase just linearly. However the
reality is very different. The reality
is that if we put some noise into the
mix and the noise is represented by that
uh gray area you can see that the
rewarded magnitude by adding just a
little noise is going to be huge. It's
going to be huge. So it can be 20 or it
can be 40. So it's huge. So what this
means in terms of Laughlin's uh uh fly
experiment is that assuming that this
was the brain how the the brain was
encoding value, the brain would be very
wasteful on encoding all of the possible
rewards at the same at the same rate or
at the same probability. So that would
be very wasteful in terms of energy for
the brain. So the reality as we came to
know is that that that the optimal way
of allocating uh energy resources for
the brain is to allocate them for those
events that came up more likely. So
that's a key aspect. Now another
important thing is that this also tells
us that the violations commonly
discovered by Allayi Cannaman Traverski
and other behavioral economists perhaps
weren't actually violations to rational
choice theory perhaps rational choice
theory was was wrong and in reality
those decisions are in fact optimal are
in fact normative but normative under
the assumptions that we have
thermodynamic constraints that we have a
limited representational capacity So if
we assume that we have those limits on
representation then those decisions
become rational.
All right. So then how should value be
represented in the brain? Let's remember
from Barlo's efficient coding hypothesis
narrow neural systems involved to
maximize information transmission while
minimizing metabolic cost. So let's see
the sigmoidal curve in the in the panel
C. So that's basically the sigmoid
function that we just showed you. And
notice that it's remarkably similar to
the value function that Kenneth and
Tverki discovered through the behavioral
experiments the that that the the very
well-known loss aversion sigmoidal
function. And also notice that the
optimal precision allocation produced a
curve that is reference dependent that
is a reference dependent uh response
function. Um so basically what what this
means is that what behavioral economists
interpret as cognitive biases might
actually be uh an optimal representation
or an optimal computation of the brain
of value under biological constraints.
So basically we can see that notice the
what I just told you the gray area if we
assume uniform precision in the lower
right hand side corner in B the the
noise made that the reward magnitude was
huge. So the amount of energy
expenditure is going to be huge.
However, if we assume the sigmoidal
function which uh that would be the
function that we would get as we saw
with llings under thermodynamic
constraints that noise is very small
that the the reward magnitude is very
small. So that's basically the the
evidence or the yeah I mean the
demonstration that the brain is very
efficient what when using that sigmoidal
shape instead of using that uniform
shape.
All right. Now moving to neuroeconomics.
Basically neuroeconomics uh arise mainly
from combining neuroscience, psychology
and economics. And one of the leading
figures I'm going to tell you about uh
well some of the leading figures uh
let's uh let's start with uh David
Hager. David Hager which was if I
remember correctly an NYU came up with
uh with other authors like Simon Chel
and Karandini with famously divisive
normalization model. So what is divisive
normalization? So device normalization
is basically uh a computational
algorithm that the brain uses to well
originally it was it was used to explain
how the brain or how the the V1 uh
primary visual cortex encoded visual
information. So basically if we look
into the graph what what Hager and
colleagues pretty much found is that
neuro I mean neurons in the retina
basically encode information but they
don't encode it as as we saw with
Laughlin equally or uniformly. What they
do is that they divide the specific
input that or that the excite the
excitatory input that we want to see it
divides them by the pool of surrounding
neurons. So, so, so by dividing them by
that that pool of surrounding activity
of of neurons, what it's basically doing
is it's subtracting it's taking out that
redundant information. So that's pretty
much what it's doing when dividing it by
that by those surrounding neurons. So
that makes the again that makes the the
brain or in this case the the neurons in
the retina much more effective or much
more efficient. And if we see how do the
the the value encoding looks like. So we
can see that the graph in the right
looks pretty much the same as Laughlin's
uh graph for fly photo receptors. Later
on uh other neurokconomists came to see
that that divisive normalization
algorithm not only worked for accounting
for information in the primary visual
cortex, it also worked for all
information for sound and also for
encoding value in the posterior parital
cortex. So basically uh what later came
came to be known is that it appears that
device normalization is a canonical
narrow neural computation and not only
for vision and later on uh Louie Kenlie
showed that value representations in the
brain can be well described vivasive
normalizations. Also by this time uh
neuroeconomies have found have founded
the the main brain areas that that are
probably responsible for the main
activities of encoding value
specifically the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex and the straightum. So even
though there are other brain areas that
also play a role for example the amydala
lines of cases and al like the
vententral prefrontal cortex and the
striatum are are definitely have been
shown to be the key areas involving
value representation in the brain. Now
later on Paul Glitchimer uh here which
is also a professor at NYU. He actually
directs the neural institute at NYU. Uh
came to I mean just keep keep ke kept
working on this work with also with
David Hager and pretty much imported
device of normalization from
neuroscience from vision neuroscience
into economics and later uh with joint
work with Timula which is now now I
think in in Australia or in Israel uh
later uh they they published their work
on expected subjective value theory. Now
notice that subjective value theory
looks a lot like Savage uh subjective
value theory but this is a narrow
science-based subjective value theory.
So even though it's it looks a little
the same is not the same. So basically
they he established he took this device
normalization model and established that
uh and he used this formula to say that
the brain can basically
well that value representation in the
brain can be shown to follow this exact
formula. So what this formula is saying
is subjective value SD is dependent on
the excitatory value the value that I'm
trying to evaluate or the payoff divided
by a fixed constant plus the payoff what
we call the payoff expectation which is
the normalization factor which in the in
the case of vision neuroscience what the
sum was the sum activity of the pool of
neurons but in an economic
interpretation it could be the
alternative options options. So if we
have a menu of economic options, it will
be the the the average sum of those
options. If we are speaking about
intertemporal choice, it could be the
the average uh the weighted average of
those payoffs across time. So basically
again what we are saying is
is that the value representation in the
brain is context dependent. So what what
what this model is basically bringing to
economics is context modulation context
modulation in economic decision making
in the brain and I mean just for you to
know in the standard devices
normalization model here use usually FR
instead of ST to represent that ST can
be interpreted as neuronal firing so
it's literally a neurohysiological
model uh for economic value
representation
All right.
Now, moving on.
If we dig deeper into the model, we can
see that it has two key parameters. It
has alpha and m. So, what alpha is uh in
the in this type of model, it's
considered a free parameter. But in a in
an economic context, it can be
considered for example the risk
tolerance. its because that parameter
alpha controls the shape or the
curvature of the of the function. So
notice that if we increase alpha we get
pretty much in the in in panel A we get
B's utility function the same function
that Daniel Verni discovered like 200
years ago if we increase alpha we get
that that type of shape and then if we
decrease it a bit we get canverki
sigmoidal function so the key aspect
here is that this model is a more
general model because it allows us to
account for different utility functions
that had come up in both neocclassical
economics and behavioral economics. But
again this is a
neuroscientific physiological
representation
uh it just happens to look like
neocclassical and behavioral economics
and also form which again is the pay of
expectation uh what it does is that that
it moves the the mean the center of the
of the of the utility function. So we
can move it by increasing m. And what
that means in terms of basian of of
basian decision making is that depending
on my experience on past outcomes on my
past preferences that's going to shape
that's going to move the shape or the
the center point of my objective value
uh utility function. All right.
Um
yep.
Now moving on into act the active
inference framework. uh I mean this is
going to be uh pretty got pretty
familiar to many people here listen
listening to the talk in the community
but uh for those maybe not so well
acquainted with uh the free energy
principle uh we can trace back let's say
the yeah the like the intellectual
origins of the free energy principle to
hemholds who basically uh discovered
that that we have as we have as
individual unconscious inference
And this might might sound very similar
to what Paul Samson said that we cannot
look inside brains to see what
preference people do do people have.
That was pretty much the the same type
of things. But he was speaking about
neurohysiological processes. Later on,
Hinton and Moonfort uh came up with the
first energy based models uh which later
became very famous for example with the
Bolsman machine uh and those were the
very the very type of uh the very first
models that were energy based and that
considered hidden or latent variables
that so that's a key a key aspect and
specifically Moon for came up with the
basin approach to vision later on
predictive coding with row and Balard uh
pretty much uh for predictive processing
uh lay laid out the the ground for for
later on professor Fristston to came up
with a free energy principle and it's
let's say practical framework which is
the active inference framework and later
on with basin mechanics. Uh so the key
aspect here is that we can regard
economic choices essentially as
predictions about future act outcomes or
beliefs about states under uncertainty
because even if we are going to make a
an economic decision in the present we
are going to see we're going to think
about future outcomes about how much
would will like this chocolate this
coffee what if I spend my salary in this
or that how is going to impact that on
my finances. So almost all economic
choices naturally inevitably have to do
about have to do with the future and
have some uncertainty embedded in them.
Now
for those who are who maybe are not
acquainted with the free energy
principle but for those who are uh I
think it's never uh it's never wasteful
to go again to explain it. So basically
that what the free energy principle
claims or says is that I if we observe
that things exist if if something
persists over time and and its identity
can be re identifiable in the
environment. It has a given structure
then it must be true that it must encode
or instantiate a statistical model of
its environment or we can call it a
generative model an internal model of
its environment. There we have the
famous uh free energy principle formula
and the key aspect here is that the free
energy principle has two aspects. It has
an accuracy term which basically that
could be uh rendered as we're going to
see later as the expected utility in in
economics expected utility theory the
log evidence and that's basically how
accurate are my my predictions. I wanted
to have the the most accurate
predictions. So that's basically the
like reward in terms of reinforcement
learning and in terms of the complexity
term the complexity terms brings into
the model uh an entropic an entropic
term. So what does entropy bring into
the model? It brings flexibility. It it
brings flex flexibility for for example
in e in the economic context flexibility
for preferences. We have to we want to
be flexible in our preference because we
have uncertainty in the world. So
perhaps now I like something but later I
will not like that and I would prefer uh
X to Y. So basically the model can
account for uh for biases that that were
regarded in behavioral economics like
like intritive decisions uh or just
flexibility in in preferences. Now the
question would be does the expected
values theory that uses the devising
normalization model from their economics
can emerge from the perceptual inference
uh part of the free energy principle. So
that's the question that we are asking
and why specifically the perceptual
inference in the perception action cycle
of the free energy principle because
even though active inference is well the
active part or the action the action
part of the cycle is very important
because when we have references we have
preferred outcomes we're going to be
looking for information we're going to
engage in information gathering
activities. However, the initial value
representation in the brain is going to
be perceptual. It's going to be
perception. So the so we can say that
the if the model exists is going to be
living in the perceptual inference
section and later on we can add the
information gathering aspect uh through
the the action component in the model.
So as we mentioned what active inference
does is that it assumes that agents and
in this case economic agents are not
passive observers. They are going to
look to fulfill their preferences their
outcomes and to have better information
to make better economic choices. Now as
we just saw if we take out the
complexity or the entropic term from the
free energy principle what we get is
just the expected log probability of our
preferred outcomes that can be more or
less approximated by the expected
utility in economics. So that formula
that expected utility in economics was
basically what Bonoyman and Morgansen uh
formulated uh almost 100 years ago. So
basically in if we think about this
model in an economic context what we
call preferences in economics can be
regarded as prior beliefs or preference
distributions under the free energy
framework. Now what is that? I mean how
is active inference useful for
economics? Well, the first thing is that
it can unify the epistemic value or the
information gathering aspect of of
economic behavior or strategic behavior
and decision making. Um, also as as I
just mentioned epistemic versus pragmat
pragmatic actions. So I mean economic
agents uh and strategic agents need to
evaluate the cost of gathering
information versus increasing their
precision. So again as we mentioned uh
having unlimited precision is not viable
having having more uh well less
stochastic or less noisy decisions is
costly. So we need to evaluate the cost
or just just weight the cost of those
decisions. And finally, as we also know,
there's a lot of research coming out in
the on the free energy principle and
active inference applications to
artificially intelligent systems that
this framework allows us to track back
uh all of the specific decisions and all
of the specific preferences and pretty
much all of the parameters in the model.
So, contrary to other machine learning
techniques like neuronet networks, this
is not a black box. This is a
transparent model that that allows us to
trace back every decision made in the
model to the specific parameters of the
model. So it's a very transparent and
explainable uh decisions uh decision
system if implemented specifically in an
in an in an AI system.
All right. So moving on to the key uh
key let's say contribution of the paper.
So what we just we just uh we showed is
that if we if you start from the free
energy principle and the expected free
energy, you can derive from that the
devices normalization model as assumed
by the expected subjective value theory
of Glenmer and Timola. And basically if
you do all of the math you can get to
the free energy minimization and get M
like the the internal model or the the
the mean under perceptual inference as
that formula. And we can see in the in
the lower lower uh box that that formula
and each component of the formula can be
mapped directly to the subjective uh
value expected subjective value theory
or the divisive normalization model. So
what the lema says is under a
hierarchical generative model with gauss
and priors and likelihoods perceptual
inference through the free energy
principle converges to a representation
which is that representation there which
is equivalent to divisive normalization.
So what is going on? As we as we said
the uppers upper part of the of the
model is basically the predicted value
the exact the excitatory value that we
are trying to encode and we are dividing
it by a baseline plus uh weighted
average which is in this case is a
precision weighted prediction error
minimization term. And again what we are
doing is we are subtracting we are
taking out all of the irre all of the
irrelevant information that we already
know. We already know from our
experience from past outcomes or or we
just don't care it's irrelevant
information or so we are taking it out
by making that division in order to just
focus on the specific value that we are
trying to encode. So in short what we
are doing is that we can show that the
free energy principles allows us to
account for context dependent
economic decisions and also reference
dependent economic decisions as posited
by behavioral economic theory. But in
this case again is not
a bias in is not a heristics per se.
It's actually an optimal decision. It's
a normative model. So in the case of uh
of the economic uh let's say language
this is a rational model of economic
decision- making but it's rational by
assuming thermodynamic constraints. Uh
so that in that sense it becomes
rational. So we're really we're really
excited about it about this because what
it says is that from neuroscience we can
derive some of the let's say of the
the the oldest paradigms in economic
theory but we can test them and validate
them both mathematically in this case
but also empirically because I didn't
mention that but the divisive
normalization algorithm has been tested
empirically in humans and in non-human
animals as well uh from I don't know
like monkeys and I think even bees. So
basically we can see that the device
normalization model is a very robust
model and as many people in the
community here in the active community
know the free energy principle as well
can be mapped into a narrow process
theory. So moving into that basically
the future directions of our work is
that we want to oper operationalize this
work into a into the let's say op into
the practical version of the active
inference framework which is in in into
a graph into a partially observable
markup decision process. So basically
what we want to build is an agent uh an
agent that makes economic or financial
decisions in the market. And how is this
modeled better than for example uh a
transformer type of architecture that
does this type of economic decision
making. Number one it's the traceability
as we just mentioned. uh when we when we
use transformer like architectures or
neural network architectures for things
like financial decision making or things
like health uh decision making it's very
sensible because we don't really have we
we cannot really account for what the
model is doing or how the model is
coming up with its output in this case
with this type of graph uh in focus we
can have traceability of the system
number two everything is explicit. All
of the parameters are explicit. Uh so
that's another thing we can for example
uh make beta and and the rest of and
gamma and the rest of the parameters
very very explicit. For example, we can
uh use gamma as investor confidence. We
can use beta as decision uncertainty in
the model. And finally it can uh we can
use the the basian update uh belief uh
equations to account for adaptive
learning because naturally when you
become an investor or for any other type
of economic decision setting you learn
as we just mentioned you learn about
past outcomes if you have bad outcomes
while investing you usually become more
conservative. Uh your risk tolerant
changes your priority and and financial
objectives change with time. So, so
basically this model also allows us to
have that flexibility uh for uh for for
how the agent is adapting in the
environment. So, basically this is a a
future work that we are that we're
currently building and we hope to have
empiric empiric uh results perhaps later
this year or the the beginning of 2026.
So, this is pretty much the the future
we're working on. Um, and yeah, and
that's pretty much the end of of the
talk. Uh, we'll open up the the space
for questions. Thank you, Daniel. And
here's my my contact and my LinkedIn as
well. If anybody listening wants to add
me or contact me, uh, I'm all ears.
Thank you, Daniel. And thank you to all
all for listening.
Thank you. Very cool.
All right.
Well, those watching live can write a
question in the live chat. Let us begin
with Jack. Would you like to say hello
and give any initial reflection or
question?
Hey there. Yeah, I mean I really find it
fascinating that what we might consider
biases in a lot of economics kind of
turn out to be optimal. Um,
you know, one thing I I want to
understand more is why
is it important that you can derive some
of these up-to-ate economics models from
active inference? Like what does that
say that they are so related? Um, and
um,
is it natural to think that they would
be like when you set out? you think
maybe like maybe this won't work like
tell me bit a bit more about the fact
that they are so related. Yeah. Well, I
think that um a long-standing
inspiration in the economics field is to
make economics as scientific as possible
within the social sciences. So
historically economics imported a lot of
things from physics um like I don't know
like thermodynamic equilibrium and many
other things uh just precisely like like
like trying to trying to make it as
scientific as possible but what happened
is that it became highly technical uh
and highly mathematical but always
assuming that that economic agents
behave as if so theoretically. So just
like like a highly theoretical field. So
what happened initially with behavioral
economics and I think can happen now
with neuroeconomics and by importing uh
tools like the free energy principle or
methods is that we can make economic
theory
where we can validate or we can test
economic theory in real life experiments
uh or or in or in my case also
mathematically but mathematically like
the Pythagorean theorem. I mean even we
can demo even even though we can
demonstrate the py the pythagoran
theorem mathematically we can also test
it in reality. What happened with
economic theories is that we prove them
mathematically assuming certain very uh
implausible axioms and later we just
said well it's demonstrated but assuming
those actions. So what this allows us to
do is to prove it mathematically as well
but by accounting for a in this case for
a narrow process theory that can be
testable in uh in empirically. So that I
think that that's a key a key insight
and in this case a principle uh I mean
if we as myself and I think that many
people listening in the community assume
I I don't know I mean I don't want to
use the the word true but it's a very
good model to explain how uh to explain
self-organization and how things exist.
If we think that that's a very useful
model then it should apply to this as
well. So that I think that's another
thing on on the second part of the
question.
Thank you. Well, I'll ask a question
then Jack you can you can go again or
I'll read one from the live chat. So how
does this help us think about the
microeconomic
macroeconomic
relationship like what what do we get
from this cognitive approach or from
basian statistical approaches that might
connect those two differently than how
they're understood to be connected now.
Yeah. I mean, a recent trend that that
that I think that has been going on in
in the last decade perhaps in in just
standard economics is that there has
been u let's say uh I mean let's just
say that that macroeconomics has has
decreasing popularity. So for example,
famously MIT is no longer uh requiring
to take macroeconomics as a mandatory
course even within uh within the
economics major. So that tells you that
that in a sense uh we are migrating uh
to yeah I mean ju just to explain
economic in the individual level and
then try to go up to add them up. So I
mean at least from my perspective
the future of macroeconomics and again
that's my own my personal opinion would
be starting with these type of
empirically grounded microeconomic
models. Uh so we can regard these type
of approaches like a a like a
microeconomic model and then moving it
up in in a microeconomic setting but but
relying on complex systems in in complex
adaptive systems. uh so in that sense
again I think that the energy principle
uh blends very nicely with that type of
approach.
So that would be my my opinion on that.
Yeah. Go ahead Jack.
Maybe I have a more general question and
it might not be answerable by you, but I
wonder why biology would be so optimal.
Um I guess um because you know when
economists do experimental research and
they find oh maybe people have biases
and stuff maybe
maybe that makes sense like why would we
be optimal but then kind of what you're
saying is well we are optimal given the
constraints that we have the fact that
we're biological and we don't have
infinite energy and things like this.
So, um I don't know if that's a
question, but more a comment of um I
just don't understand too much about
biology and like how optimal is it given
the constraints that we have.
Mhm. Mhm. Well, I mean what I would I
mean I think that Daniel is very
equipped to answer that. But I what I
would say about that is for example the
the other day I was reading a paper from
Maxwell Ramstead and he said that
that we can regard the free energy
principle as a sort of generalization of
the second law of thermodynamics.
Uh so in that sense
what we could say is that for things to
exist and not to dissipate uh they need
to be extremely effective. So it's very
I mean just for the laws of physics is
very unlikely for very complex systems
like us and brains like us to exist to
came to be and to and to actually I mean
kept existing it's very unlikely. So in
that sense I think that uh I mean we can
regard uh our structure our decision-
making systems I mean just how we
function as very optimal given the the
the unlikelihood of us to to exist
specifically given the complexity that I
mean the complexity of our structure. So
that would be my claim but I but but
surely I'm not a biologist so I don't
know Daniel if you have something to say
about that.
Yes. So that history you told of the
decision-m and the way that that that
that was great as a non economist and it
reminded me of optimal foraging theory
where sort of a simple version of
optimal foraging theory would be like
how much resources are being obtained
per unit time. Then once you start to
bring in different trade-offs like water
loss or the costs of movement, you start
to get closer and closer to empiricism.
And then the sort of um death blow to
that just seeds per minute
uh measurement is the subjectivity of
beliefs like well there's predation
risk. So you could ask is this G
behavior optimal given predation risk?
But then in a way when you get to the
subjectivity of predation risk that's
like kind of asking well is this an
optimal invest investment strategy given
the volatility profile and it it may or
may not be. There may be a better
performing trade strategy given a gi
market condition. But in a way once you
get to subjectivity which is the sort of
nucleus of decision-m
you get to that tautology
which is like well they're acting as if
these are the conditions. So given their
subjective evaluation
they are acting in this baze optimal
way. And so in a way that sort of um
like
fake out almost like oh it's rational
but that's so much of the debate that at
least I've heard from afar is this
debate what is rationality are are
people in their decision-m rational or
not and it's like when we're doing baze
optimal modeling even if it's going to
be a pathological state it's like
there's something about the
parameterization
where it is optimal for this repetitive
behavior to arise or is it it's not that
everyone around this person or the
person themsel wants to be having this
thought or action per se but optimal
doesn't mean that it means like the ball
is at the bottom of the bowl but the
bowl shape so it's like the starting
point for baze optimal modeling is that
by taking constraints into account
including interior constraints,
subjective constraints and evaluations,
then it's ta logical and not really an
account to say that it's optimal. It's
just sort of things are how they are and
all the work goes into structuring and
doing the inference on what those
constraints are.
And so it's like the framework says less
about what's optimal,
but it lets us look at traders with a
variety of portfolios and say we we're
already going to take it as a granted
that they are acting in their own B
optimal way. So what is the structure
and the parameterization that enables
that and in that way feels like it moves
forward.
Not trying to imagine a time before
there was this debate of rational or
irrational but but just as you
structured the presentation moving to a
place where we can empirically ask what
are those
objective and subjective constraints
that make decision-m actors act the way
they act.
you're in the AI program. So just how
did that like come to be and did you how
did you come to this economics
topic in that program? Right. Right. Um
basically my background uh originally is
in finance or let's say financial
economics. I later pursued uh graduate
studies in engineering mathematics.
uh and while at that I I did my my
thesis on complex adapt adaptive systems
or complex systems engineering so and
that inevitably or eventually led me to
active influence of the free energy
principle u and at the same time well
when I became very excited about that
like I don't know like three four years
ago uh I also pursued the graduate
studies in uh in psychology and and
focused on mathematical psychology so
that was like the natural bridge for for
me to go into free the free energy
principle. So later when thinking about
what field I wanted to pursue for my
PhD, I thought well I mean usually
economists are very I don't know I don't
know why but they usually work like a
lot in silos. I mean they they work on
things like I don't know like law and
political science and so sociology but
not so much in other areas like I don't
know like not not not so much in in
technology and stuff like that usually.
Uh also in finance I mean they just
don't work in these type of things. Uh,
and in psychology, I mean, we I didn't
have a I mean, at least here in Mexico,
we didn't have we we I don't think we
have a very strong mathematical
psychology program. So, the only place I
thought I could merge
decision sciences, cognitive science and
and my interest in economics was in AI.
And given the the the recent literature
or I mean I don't know the last five
years the literature that has been
coming up about applying the active
inference framework for practical
applications uh I don't know like
inverses and stuff like that. I just
thought that that was like the perfect
route for
so that that's pretty much the story.
Which economic actors or firms
would have a different day-to-day
experience? How if these kinds of
relationships were better understood?
Well, I think that for example on the
type of agent I am uh I intend to
develop.
one one reason why I mean I don't know
if you you have a different opinion but
uh I haven't seen many AI agents for
economic advisory I mean there's some
there's some there's some robo advisors
but they're very let's say very simple
uh and again the reason why they're
they're very simple I think is that it
has been proven and it has been tested
that LLMs cannot plan so for example The
other day I was listening to a talk from
professor Carlo Friston and he said that
at least for him an agent for it to be
an agent needs to be able to plan. So I
I completely share that insight. So if
he if it could mean if it has been
proven that LLMs cannot plan then at
least for me they are not very useful
for financial advisory because the key
for financial advisory is financial
planning. So, so in that sense I think
that looking for other type of
architectures in this case the partially
observable market decision process that
that that is proposed by the active
inference framework could be better for
that I mean just for the fact that it
can plan and second because it's
explainable and as I was saying a key
aspect also about or the a key
disadvantage of using transformer-l like
architecture for uh some sort of
financial advisory is that it's not
explainable. So if somebody loses all of
their savings, so what's going to be the
explanation? Uh just hallucinated or or
something like that. So I think that
that's a practical application.
There will be some very interesting
economic arenas and futures with all
these different kinds of agents making
different
belief updating and policy selection. Um
yeah policy election as well.
Jack, do you have anything else you want
to ask?
No, not really. Thank you. It was really
interesting. So, what else will you do
in your PhD?
Hypothetically, but what what what what
where would you like to take in the
second half of the PhD?
Well, basically
uh finish building this this agent and
hopefully get to test it uh like in with
real people. Uh so that would be my my
intent for the next couple of years.
Anything else you want to add?
Uh well just again if somebody wants to
get in contact for I don't know any type
of research opportunity collaboration or
anything there's my email my academic
email and my LinkedIn profile as well.
So so happy to collaborate. Cool. Well
well thank you again for the very
presentation and work. Absolutely.
Thanks a lot. Okay. Till next time. See
you. Thank you. Bye.